[Music]
hard to believe it's been over 20 years
since Dawson's Creek premiered putting
Joshua Jackson james van der beek
Michelle Williams and Katie Holmes on
the map it is a little racing we do push
a lot just about every episode ever seen
we deal with real issues you can't you
can't deny the fact that 15 year-olds
are thinking about and talking about sex
thank you the virgin you're on an alien
which isn't bad no wasted moment it was
I mean greater men would be nailing
right now you wanna mean that sex okay
every time et was on the set of The WB
show in 1997 with a fresh-faced and
soft-spoken 19 year old Katie I play in
Joey Potter know my grams warned me
about you she says you're severely
troubled well no offense but your grams
is cracked and she's you know she's kind
of reserved and quiet when it comes to
lots of people yet she speaks her mind
when she's with Dawson and Pacey and Jen
um so I can relate to that I have a lot
of fun playing hey who wouldn't have fun
with those two hunky male co-stars this
morning we walked in here and started
shooting and the first thing we saw was
you and the and and James rolling around
on the I know some perks I'm just
kidding
but Katie told us she almost missed her
chance at the role I was involved in a
high school musical I had a big part in
Oh although I was until you I was still
auditioning on tape and I auditioned for
a Dawson's Creek and Senate and I saw it
and they wanted me to fly out our
opening night to go test for it and I I
couldn't I couldn't tell my friends and
all that so I was like no thanks luckily
they'd let me come the next week so I
went to LA for two days
got it how'd you feel when you got the
news I can't even describe it
only this big smile on my face disguise
[Music]
[Applause]